[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen in unserem schönen
garten
darf ich dir meine familie vorstellen
das ist meine frau
ihr name ist marit
ihr name ist marita
schön dich kennenzulernen
ich bin marit
und wie ist dein name
und dieser nette herr da drüben am grill
ist mein mann
sein name ist david
und das sind unsere beiden kinder
anna spielt mit ihrem roten
spielzeugauto
das mädchen mit dem teddybär heißt lea
sie dir nur an
sind die beiden nicht allerliebst
wenn es doch nur immer so wäre
und hier ist das neueste mitglied
unserer familie
sein name ist balu und
hier ist das neueste mitglied unserer
familie
sein name ist balu
ist er nicht süß
hast du lust auf eine kleine tour rund
um das haus
das ist die vor der seite meines hauses
meinen garten hast du bereits gesehen
ich glaube du hast da etwas verwechselt
mein lieber
wessen haus ist dass
dessen haus ist das
bitter entschuldige liebling
natürlich ist es unser haus
wir haben es schließlich gemeinsam
gekauft
das ist richtig und
wir haben es zusammen abbezahlt und
wir haben es zusammen abbezahlt
darum gehört es jetzt uns und nicht mehr
der bank
und das sind unsere beiden autos
unser auto ist das gelbe
das rote auto gehört nicht uns sondern
deinem vater
deine haare
das ist richtig aber das müssen ja nicht
alle wissen
du hast recht es ist mir einfach so
rausgerutscht
wir sind am ende unserer hausführung
das nächste mal schauen wir das innere
unseres hauses an
wir sind am ende unserer hausführung
das nächste mal schauen wir das innere
unseres hauses an
und jetzt zeigen wir dir noch weitere
beispiele zum thema passiv pronomen
also bleib dran
bilde sätze wie im folgenden beispiel
und klavier
das ist dein klavier
ich und klavier
das ist mein klavier
bist du bereit für weitere beispiele
los geht s
ich und haus
das ist mein haus
und haus
das ist dein haus
das ist sein haus
ich und katze
das ist meine katze
und katze
das ist deine katze
das ist seine katze
ist das dein buch
das dein buch
bitte entschuldigen was hast du gesagt
ich habe dich gefragt ob das dein buch
ist
das ist eine sehr spezielle frage
schließlich befinden wir uns in einer
bibliothek
das ist eine sehr spezielle frage
schließlich befinden wir uns in einer
bibliothek
natürlich ist das nicht mein buch
oder sind das dort deine bücher
nein das sind nicht meine bücher
das sind nicht meine bücher
siehst du
ich glaube jetzt habe ich es verstanden
gut haben wir das geklärt
dieser meinung bin ich auch
großartig
hast du eine ahnung wo sich unser auto
befindet
du wolltest sagen unsere autos
sehr witzig
bist du nicht mit unserem auto gefahren
warum fragst du
du bist mit dem auto gefahren also hast
du das auto auch parkiert
da ist etwas wahres dran
dann sag bescheid wenn du unser auto
gefunden hast
guten tag herr meier
guten tag herr nachbar
wie geht es ihnen heute
ist das nicht ein herrlicher tag
perfekt um unsere vorgärten auf
vordermann zu bringen
apropos vorgarten
ist dass ihr hundehaufen auf meinem
rasen
selbstverständlich ist das nicht mein
hundehaufen
hundehaufen und
wessen hundehaufen ist es dann
und wessen hundehaufen ist es dann
das sieht mir ganz nach dem hundehaufen
von meinem hund aus
sie haben doch gesagt das sei nicht ihr
hundehaufen
ist es auch nicht
das ist der hundehaufen meines hundes
[Applaus]
war das video hilfreich für dich
schreibe es in die kommentare
bis zum nächsten
[Musik]
vergiss nicht das video zu leiten
kommentiere und abonniere unseren kanal
hast du gewusst du kannst auch mitglied
der halo deutsche schule werden
es gibt viele vorteile
auf unserer kanalseite kannst du dich
ein schreiben
werde online schüler der halo deutsche
schule
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video